ball utah now their bench is just two
out of 12 from beyond the arc
ross throw it down
throw it down russ
down the middle he goes then he gets a
technical for taunting but
i mean he looked back and rudy gobert
and handsome
with some words that was so clear that's
what russ
has been known for doing though getting
into the paint and then exploding did he
ever explode
over the top of gobert
oh wow that's just a monster dunk
by russell westbrook
[Applause]
this is one of those where you say
i'll live with that technical
[Applause]
that was monster type that has
lit this crowd up
wow
and that was a trampoline act there
by
russell westbrook i mean this is what
we've seen his entire career we always
talk about everything's predicated on
his explosiveness to the rim
it's been a frustrating year he's taken
a ton
a ton of criticism so far this year
that's what you really got to do make
kevin durant play on both ends
west brook oh my goodness gracious
not many players in the league can do
that durant with another rebound
[Applause]
westbrook
oh it goes in
[Applause]
this is on a set piece coming out of
bounds on the other end
and he punished that reel
look at this here you talking about
going
94 feet with russell westbrook
wiggins has it knocked away westbrook
smells it like a shark smelling blood
russell westbrook i mean
just a nose for the basketball you give
him even the slightest opening and he is
going to take it the distance as he does
here
21 points for davis
and westbrook
dunk we talked about somebody stepping
up closing out the path to the basket
adam's the rebound
come on he cannot allow oh my goodness
oh that is illegal what he does
they are up
it's just a big arena oh watch this yeah
just watch now as he makes this move and
then he decides
no do you notice the defender on the
left i'm not getting near you
that was an express train coming
okc's last 19 points
[Music]
that's rude folks
wow
thunder by three with 7.1 remaining
westbrook shows from the basketball
ghosts and win
on the yard
rush throw it down
throw it down russ
down the middle he goes then he gets a
technical for ponding getting into the
paint and then exploding did he ever
explode
over the top of gobert
oh wow that's just a monster dunk
by russell westbrook
this is one of those where you say